you
what explains North Korea's relentless
quest for nukes and missiles these
programs were obviously not some
bargaining chip and regime survival is
hardly their only purpose my take the
North Korean regime intends eventually
to fight a limited nuclear war in the
Korean Peninsula and win it
Pyongyang plans confrontations that can
win the North Korean regime is not
suicidal it could not have lasted this
long if it were its threats and
provocations are never a sudden
impulsive outburst
they're always carefully planned
rehearsed well in advance if Pyongyang
can force an American president to blink
in a future Korean crisis in the US
South Korean military alliance of
collapsed US forces will be out and the
Kim family regime will take a giant step
towards settling the still unfinished
Korean War on its terms all the pieces
for the North's design are slowly but
deliberately falling into place
the nukes the missiles the cyber war
component America and her allies must
wake up to that design and counter it
while there is still time to learn more
about my take on North Korea check the
links in the description below also let
us know what other topics you want our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to subscribe for more research and
videos from AEI